Traduttore: Veronica Viscardi
Revisore: Barbara Nettl
Le aziende responsabili e sostenibili
sono aziende
che fanno più soldi degli altri?
Purtroppo l'idea è che non sia così.
Purtroppo pensiamo che i furbi sono quelli
che fanno più soldi degli altri.
Però nei prossimi pochi minuti
io vi voglio convincere
che le aziende responsabili e sostenibili
sono le aziende più competitive di tutte.
Però inizio con una storia personale.
Inizio con una storia personale...
Ho passato gli ultimi 15 anni lavorando.
Tutta la mia vita era basata sul lavoro.
Ho partorito con il telefonino in mano,
rispondendo alle e-mail.
Ho allattato
in consiglio di amministrazione.
Ho perso i primi due compleanni
di mio figlio, che ha due anni e mezzo,
per cui due su due.
Ero in viaggio e non ho potuto
star con lui.
E un giorno ho deciso
che questo era troppo.
Non andava bene, la mia vita
non era quella che io volevo.
Per cui sono andata
dal mio direttore generale
e gli ho detto:
"Vorrei una posizione part-time".
Lui mi ha guardato e mi ha detto:
"Part-time? C'è la fila di gente,
di uomini, che sta aspettando
di coprire la tua posizione.
Se non sei disponibile a lavorare
24 ore al giorno, quella è la porta".
Per la prima volta in tutta la mia vita
ho toccato con mano
cosa volesse dire lavorare in un'azienda
irresponsabile e insostenibile.
Quindi da allora cerco di convincere
le persone a capire
che le aziende responsabili
e sostenibili sono le aziende
che realmente riescono
ad essere più competitive.
Viviamo in un mondo dove riceviamo
tantissimi messaggi.
Per cui è importante capire cos'è
la sostenibilità e cosa la responsabilità.
Prima di tutto la responsabilità
è la responsabilità nei confronti
delle persone.
Le persone che lavorano nelle aziende,
i clienti, i nostri fornitori.
Poi dobbiamo essere sostenibili
economicamente.
L'azienda che non è sostenibile
economicamente
è l'azienda più irresponsabile
perché chiude e licenzia tutti.
E poi dobbiamo essere sostenibili
nei confronti dell'ambiente
e del pianeta in cui viviamo.
Le aziende sostenibili
sono anche le aziende
che rispettano l'ambiente dove viviamo.
Viviamo in un mondo pieno di messaggi,
siamo bombardati dalla pubblicità.
Abbiamo dei clienti
assolutamente infedeli.
I ragazzi giovani cambiano marca
continuamente.
Prima compravamo
lo stesso detersivo tutta la vita,
e adesso cambiamo,
perché se c'è un'offerta
compriamo un detersivo differente.
Il mondo dove viviamo ha delle risorse
estremamente limitate.
Così limitate che fra qualche anno
finiranno.
O rispettiamo questo mondo
o non riusciremo a vivere in futuro.
È difficile vendere
anche perché l'1% della popolazione
possiede il 50% della ricchezza
che c'è nel mondo.
O vendiamo a quell'1%
o vendiamo al restante 99.
Però è difficile.
Siamo collegati ad internet tutto il tempo
e quando siamo collegati ad internet
parliamo di marche.
E quando parliamo delle marche
in Facebook o in Twitter
normalmente parliamo male di loro.
Le aziende hanno fatto
tante cose sbagliate,
hanno dato messaggi scorretti
con le pubblicità.
E oggigiorno siamo scettici,
marketing ci sembra qualcosa
come di negativo.
La gente vuole che le aziende
siano trasparenti,
e questo è difficile
per la maggior parte di loro.
In più, dobbiamo renderci conto
che le persone chiedono alle aziende
che le aziende siano una forza
per fare il bene,
non semplicemente
che vendano dei prodotti.
Questo non è sufficiente.
In più vendere, in questo mondo,
è difficile.
Quasi tutti i prodotti alla fine
sono uguali.
Quasi tutti i telefonini funzionano.
Quasi tutti i prodotti che compriamo
al supermercato sono più o meno buoni.
Vendere in questo mondo è difficile.
Siamo immersi in moltitudini di marche.
Dobbiamo differenziarci.
Ma questa differenza
non è sufficiente di per sé.
Essere differenti nel mercato
non è sufficiente.
Se il cliente non apprezza
questa differenza,
se non è disposto a pagare
il prezzo di questa differenza,
siamo solo differenti,
ma non vendiamo di più.
Sappiamo però
che il 40% dei clienti vorrebbe
che le marche rappresentassero
qualcosa in più
che semplicemente il beneficio utile
del prodotto.
Un telefonino che funzioni,
un detersivo che lava, eccetera.
Sappiamo che il 40% delle persone
che stanno lì fuori
vogliono delle marche
che rappresentino dei valori.
Però la maggior parte delle aziende
non sono in grado
di rappresentare questi valori.
Però ci sono alcune aziende
che grazie alla sostenibilità
e grazie alla responsabilità sociale
riescono ad essere differenti
e riescono ad essere
più competitive nel mercato.
Vediamo degli esempi.
Vodafone non vendeva nessun prodotto
in Africa e in India,
perché in questi paesi la gente
non paga il telefonino.
Però c'era un'opportunità di mercato.
L'opportunità di mercato era
che la gente non ha accesso alle banche.
Per cui avere denaro liquido
in Africa o in India è molto difficile.
In più, quando la gente va alla banca
e cerca di fare un bonifico,
la persona che c'è dietro lo sportello
si tiene una commissione,
e normalmente questa commissione
non è così legale.
Per cui Vodafone
vede un'opportunità nel mercato.
Decide di trasformarsi
in una banca online.
Grazie al telefonino le persone
possono pagare nei negozi,
possono fare piccoli bonifici,
possono anche chiedere dei micro-crediti.
Grazie a questo lavoro
e a questa opportunità
che ha colto Vodafone,
un ultimo studio di McKinsey
ha detto che nei prossimi 10 anni
il prodotto interno lordo
di questi due Paesi aumenterà del 6%.
Un altro esempio è Walmart.
Walmart è uno dei supermercati
più importanti degli Stati Uniti,
e probabilmente una delle marche
più odiate del mondo.
Perché sono sempre stati abbastanza
insostenibili a livello ecologico
e hanno sempre trattato
un po' male i loro dipendenti.
Quindi la loro reputazione ormai
era realmente a un livello zero.
Nel 2009 decidono
che devono cambiare strategia.
E iniziano il cambio grazie a una politica
ecologica differente.
La prima cosa che fanno è decidere
di cambiare il packaging
della maggior parte dei loro prodotti.
E iniziano con i corn flakes.
Non so se avete mai aperto
una scatola di corn flakes,
quando tirate fuori il sacchetto,
la scatola è grande così,
il prodotto è così.
Mezzo pacchetto è pieno d'aria.
Cosa hanno deciso di fare:
loro sono andati dai vari fornitori
di corn flakes, e hanno detto:
"Vogliamo i pacchetti di corn flakes
grandi come la quantità del prodotto".
E perché? Perché hanno fatto
questo ragionamento.
Pacchetti più piccoli vuol dire
più pacchetti in ogni camion,
che vuol dire meno camion in circolazione,
che vuol dire meno benzina,
e ovviamente meno ossido di carbonio.
Grazie a questo perfetto sillogismo,
in tre anni hanno risparmiato
3.000 milioni di dollari solo in benzina.
E ovviamente hanno rispettato l'ecologia
in modo importante
e hanno migliorato la loro reputazione.
Un altro esempio è Patagonia.
Patagonia è una delle aziende
più importanti che producono
vestiti per andare in montagna.
Questo è il loro messaggio di marketing:
"Non comprate questa giacca".
Uno dice:
"Come non comprate questa giacca"?
Un'azienda che vuol vendere
dice di non comprare.
In più un'azienda che promette
ai propri azionisti
l'aumento del 10%
ogni anno delle loro vendite.
Qua c'è qualcosa che non quadra.
Se io chiedo alla gente
di non comprare i miei prodotti,
come posso vendere il 10% in più
dei miei prodotti ogni anno?
Perché i loro clienti sono fedelissimi.
I loro clienti considerano che chi ama
veramente la montagna, compra Patagonia.
Perché Patagonia è la marca
più rispettosa ecologicamente
nel loro sistema di produzione.
E anche se chiedono alla gente
di non comprare i propri prodotti,
di riusarli, di rammendarli, di regalarli,
purché ci sia questa cycle economy,
purché la gente continui
a utilizzare i propri prodotti,
loro fanno soldi,
perché sono i più cari di tutti.
Ma se lo possono permettere
perché i loro clienti
sono i più fedeli del mercato.
Poi ci sono dei supermercati
in Inghilterra
che stanno facendo una campagna
contro l'obesità.
Come lo fanno?
Sotto allo scontrino mettono dei bollini.
Se ci sono tanti bollini rossi vuol dire
che la spesa che la persona ha fatto
nel suo carrello è piena di grassi,
carboidrati e troppe calorie.
Quindi quando una persona
guarda lo scontrino, dice:
"Ho fatto una spesa ben poco sana".
Stanno cercando di sensibilizzare
l'opinione pubblica,
soprattutto in questi paesi
dove l'obesità è un gran problema,
soprattutto l'obesità infantile,
stanno cercando di sensibilizzare
le persone a comprare cose più sane.
Più frutta, più verdura, cose integrali,
e stanno cercando di farlo.
Poi ci sono le aziende che dicono:
"Se ti compri il mio costume,
ti trasformi in Cindy Crawford
o Naomi Campbell".
Ci sono aziende che lo promettono, eh.
E poi ci sono aziende che decidono
di dare un messaggio differente.
Come Dove.
E dicono: "Io ti vendo una crema.
Questa crema ti renderà
il più bello possibile.
Però con i tuoi pregi
e con i tuoi difetti".
E poi alla fine ci sono aziende
come Volkswagen.
Tutti sappiamo che un anno fa,
a settembre dell'anno scorso,
Volkswagen è stata la protagonista
di un grande scandalo,
perché avevano truccato il software
che misurava l'anidride carbonica
che usciva dalle macchine diesel.
È stato uno scandalo così grande,
che a parte aver quasi distrutto
la reputazione di questa azienda,
un mese dopo,
quando lo scandalo era già arrivato
sui giornali e sulle televisioni,
un mese dopo Volkswagen aveva perso
il 42% del valore del prezzo
per ogni azione in borsa.
Non recupereranno mai
la perdita di denaro che hanno avuto
a causa della propria insostenibilità.
Però non è solo per colpa
delle multinazionali, signori.
Questo è un Castell.
In Catalogna è famoso.
È una piramide umana.
Ci sono tutte queste persone,
vanno una sull'altra
e fanno una piramide umana.
Arrivano ad essere nove piani.
E la persona che è in cima
è un bambino piccolo,
che normalmente ha quattro/cinque anni.
Ogni persona che sta facendo
questo castello
ha una responsabilità incredibile.
Se solo uno di loro non mantiene
perfettamente in tensione
tutti i suoi muscoli,
la torre umana cade.
E questa è la stessa cosa
per la sostenibilità.
Ognuno di noi è responsabile
di essere sostenibile
nei confronti dell'energia,
nei confronti della natura,
nei confronti delle persone
con cui lavoriamo,
che sono i nostri clienti,
e ovviamente nei confronti
dei benefici aziendali.
Per cui vi faccio l'ultima domanda:
sapendo che tutti siamo responsabili
nei confronti
della sostenibilità aziendale,
produciamo, vendiamo e compriamo prodotti
che rispettano il futuro dei nostri figli?
Grazie.
(Applausi)